so here's the scene that I was
incredibly proud of as a director but
you know just didn't work inside of the
side of the confines of our of our film
is a scene between the characters a Quay
in a copy and I'm in are making a scene
was the intention for the audience to
really realize that that equation will
copy were husband and wife um so I had
kind of had a confrontation argument
about where Wakanda was gonna go after
the child's death you know in the in the
in the in the tribal council room I was
it was a scene with the incredible
performers from from from Danai gurira
and uh Daniel Kuya but it just didn't
working it in the film I'm really
excited for folks that folks to see it
anyway you didn't seem to have a problem
when he was thrown from the force
he was the king's challenge he lost to
lose he was not fit to lead the Chara
told me to my face of right here if you
bring back did he do it he had him in
the jatta stole him from our I don't
care
crossed off from us he married my mother
and father thirty years there's been not
justice and T Challa swore to bring him
back not taken to the UN not taken to
the CIA but bring here to us
this is what you would have me leave the
door of or to bring our children into
this world where they become conquerors
yes our children will be leaders of a
truly free well what is a tiny country
where we have to hide everything that
makes us great euro in war
but in the end it will be beautiful
a makanda will stand tall
[Music]